cette audition je vous remercie d'être
là ce matin parce que voilà la nuit a
été a été courte donc merci de votre
présence nombreuse hier pour les débats
et merci d'être d'être la ce matin nous
avons le plaisir de recevoir aujourd'hui
Monsieur Philippe Baptiste président du
Centre national d'études spatiale le
CNES que nous avons reçu il y a un peu
plus d'un ancien notre commission ainsi
qu'en septembre dernier dans le cadre de
la Conférence européenne
interparlementaire de l'espace que j'ai
l'honneur de préciser avec mes collègues
Jean-François Rapin Claude Raynal et
Gisèle Jourda évidemment pierre très
fourré accompagne le président tout le
monde connaît pierre trefforet donc
voilà je veux simplement le saluer
amicalement monsieur le Président depuis
votre dernière venue au Sénat a eu lieu
une rencontre importante pour l'avenir
de la politique spatiale européenne lors
de la dernière Conférence ministérielle
de l'Agence spatiale européenne qui
s'est tenu en novembre dernier les
ministres de l'État membre de l'ESAT ont
augmenté le budget de l'agence de 17%,
le portant à environ 17 milliards
d'euros même si l'ambition initiale
était plutôt aux alentours de 18
milliards et demi bon c'est une avancée
notable mais nous remarquons que la
France malgré une hausse de sa
contribution de 600 millions d'euros
demeurent le second souscripteur au
budget de l'ESAT avec une souscription
de 3,2 milliards d'euros contre 3,5
milliards pour nos amis allemands
au-delà de la seule question budgétaire
à mettre en perspective avec les autres
investissements nationaux de la France
en faveur de notre politique spatiale ce
sont surtout les questions de
l'influence française et de la défense
des intérêts français qui se posent
monsieur le Président les conclusions de
la dernière conférence ministérielle de
l'ESA sont-elles aujourd'hui favorables
à la France favorables à ses intérêts
sont-ils offensif défensif dans le
domaine spatial les priorités françaises
trouvent-elles toute satisfaction dans
la nouvelle feuille de route européenne
dont c'est doté les a jusqu'en 2025 les
défis à relever sont nombreux et en
priorité celui de garantir dans la durée
un accès souverain et durable à l'espace
c'est un de nos combats ici au Sénat
vous le savez la question des lanceurs
nous préoccupe nous espérons ainsi que
le vol inaugural d'Ariane 6 aura lieu
prochainement afin de pouvoir répondre
le plus rapidement possible aux besoins
commerciaux et institutionnels de
l'Europe en particulier pour la mise en
orbite de la constellation européenne de
connectivité
sécurisée la constellation iris monsieur
le Président êtes-vous aujourd'hui
confiant quant à la capacité de l'Europe
à garantir la fluidité et la cadence de
ces lancements dans la durée il faudra
également assurer le retour en vol de
vegacé et créer les conditions d'une
véritable compétition européenne
stimulante pour l'innovation
industriels en particulier pour les
gammes des micros et des mini lanceurs
sur ce point la commission des affaires
économiques se montre attentive au
développement du newspace il s'agissait
monsieur le Président de l'une des
priorités fixées lors de votre arrivée à
la présidence du CNES en plein milieu du
covid je me souviens en France nous
avons de plus en plus de startups c'est
une très très bonne chose que ce soit en
matière de lanceur d'applications
spatiale ou de surveillance de l'espace
nous ne manquons pas d'idées ni
d'entrepreneurs passionnés et engagés
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
plusieurs encore récemment
malheureusement les idées ne suffisent
pas toujours et en matière spatiale il
faut aussi un écosystème de soutien des
fonds d'investissement et de la volonté
politique pour permettre à ces
entrepreneurs de concrétiser leurs
ambitions quel bilan tirez-vous
aujourd'hui du développement du new
space en France quelles sont vos
perspectives d'action la matière je
crois que nous avons encore du chemin à
parcourir pour rivaliser avec des pays
aux ambitions spatiales toujours plus
importantes l'espace est plus que jamais
un nouveau lieu de conflictualité de
rivalité et la concurrence se déplace
désormais sur de nouveaux terrains
d'abord le terrain de l'exploration
humaine et des vols habités l'Europe ne
dispose plus aujourd'hui d'un programme
spatial habité ni d'une capsule de vol
habités alors que le premier vol décès
de Starship développé par SpaceX a eu
lieu le moins dernier il y a pourtant
quelques premières options sur la table
vous nous en parlerez sûrement par
exemple le projet Suzi d'Ariane groupe
qui ambitionne de faire du dernier étage
réutilisable d'Ariane 6 un véhicule à
tout faire en orbite basse capable de
transporter des satellites comme des
astronautes il y a également le projet
la startup franco-allemande et
exploration Company qui développe un
véhicule spatial dont l'ambition de
pouvoir transporter des marchandises à
court terme et des astronomes et des
astronautes pardon à long terme ensuite
sur le terrain de l'exploration
scientifique la contribution de la
France et de l'Europe pour la matière
n'est pas en reste en témoigne par
exemple le lancement par Ariane 5 du
télescope James web évidemment ou encore
de la sonde juice pour étudier les lunes
progresser de Jupiter enfin sur le
terrain normatif et c'est un sujet qui
nous intéresse tout particulièrement en
tant que parlementaire bien sûr la
Commission européenne est en train de se
doter d'une nouvelle stratégie de
gestion du trafic spatial adapté aux
enjeux de développement durable et de
lutte contre l'encombrement de l'espace
au niveau national une mise à jour de la
loi du 3 juin 2008 sur les opérations
spatiales a été annoncée monsieur le
Président ou en sont les discussions à
ce sujet les concertations avec les
opérateurs économiques ont-elles déjà
commencé quel serait les grandes
orientations de cette nouvelle loi sur
les opérations spatiales et non pas
spécial opération spatiale voilà je vous
je vous cède la parole surtout ces
sujets et pour répondre évidemment à ces
questions et ensuite je donnerai la
parole à mes collègues merci monsieur le
président
merci merci beaucoup madame madame la
Présidente merci de me donner l'occasion
ainsi de de m'exprimer devant
la commission des affaires économiques
du Sénat donc de très nombreuses
questions ont été ont été soulevées dans
dans votre propos introductif je vais
peut-être commencer simplement par par
un chiffre puisqu'on a commencé à parler
un tout petit peu de budget de
souscription il y avait il y a quelques
semaines à Colorado Springs une des
grandes messes du spatial très militaire
mais enfin grand-messe du spatial
américain
une conférence les budgets aujourd'hui
aux États-Unis sur les questions
spatiales tout compris civils et
militaires avoisine 70 milliards de
dollars par an
les parents les chiffres dont on a parlé
précédemment les 17 milliards de d'euros
pour l'Agence spatiale européenne
s'entendent sur trois ans
le le budget le budget du le budget du
CNES qui inclut la part la part
française de contribution à l'Agence
spatiale européenne et de l'ordre de 2,6
milliards de d'euros par an c'est
beaucoup d'argent évidemment c'est
énormément d'argent et c'est un très
gros effort de la nation mais c'est de
loin le plus gros budget spatial des
agences des agences nationales et donc
des contributions qui vont je dis pas du
tout ça dans une optique de de plein
tout de quoi que ce soit mais simplement
il faut avoir ces ordres de grandeur en
tête nous sommes dans une dynamique
absolument incroyable de relance de
l'effort spatial des états et en
particulier dans une compétition entre
la Chine et les États-Unis puisque c'est
70 milliards étaient plutôt de l'ordre
de 50 milliards il y a deux ans aux
États-Unis donc on voit bien qu'il y a
un effort qui est considérable qui est
mis sur la table aujourd'hui par par les
États-Unis et probablement aussi par la
Chine où on a une vision qui est quand
même peu plus voilà
plus parcellaire des deux de l'effort
mais qui est considérable ce qui veut
dire que derrière
si on regarde un tout petit peu et qu'on
prend un petit peu de recul sur la
position de la France et de l'Europe sur
le spatial il y a toujours eu un
différentiel entre les budgets français
européens et américain de l'autre il y a
toujours une différentielle et qui s'est
traduit par des choix qui ont été des
choix assumés de de l'Europe spatiale de
la France en particulier en disant il y
a un certain nombre de sujets qu'on
n'ouvre pas on se concentre sur un
certain nombre de thématiques on fait le
choix d'aller en avance de phase sur des
marchés commerciaux on a été les
premiers à aller avec Ariane espace sur
la commercialisation de lanceur etc donc
il y a eu des choix et qui ont été
plutôt gagnants l'Europe aujourd'hui et
leader sur l'observation de la Terre
pour toutes les questions autour du
climat de la diversité etc donc ça c'est
c'est des choses qui sont très positives
on a deux on a deux industriels qui sont
aussi dans une des positions qui sont
des positions très fortes sur les
télécoms sur sur l'observation de la
Terre sur l'optique pour la pour la
défense etc donc on a un certain nombre
de grands succès le risque potentiel qui
a évidemment avec le différentiel de
budget qui est en train de se creuser
c'est que
quel que soit les qualités des uns et
des autres et voilà on parle quand même
de différentiel qui sont gigantesques
aujourd'hui mais encore une fois c'est
pas du tout dans le dans une optique de
de c'est simplement pour il faut avoir
ce paysage en tête il faut il faut avoir
ce paysage en tête donc peut-être pour
commencer simplement sur maintenant
reprendre un petit peu plus les les
éléments autour de la contribution
France de la contribution de l'ensemble
des pays européens les arts et puis la
contribution française je pense qu'il
faut replacer déjà dans un cadre dans le
cadre national il y a l'annonce de la
première ministre qui est de mettre 9
milliards sur la table pour le spatial
dans les trois prochaines années c'est
une présentation qui est de l'ordre de
25% dans les dans les par rapport aux
années précédentes donc il y a une vraie
mobilisation du gouvernement aussi bien
sur des sujets de défense que sur les
sujets de développement économique de
sciences etc sur les questions sur les
questions spatiales donc je crois qu'on
et ça fait de d'assez loin je pense la
de la France la première puissance
spatiale européenne en termes en termes
d'engagement budgétaire c'est aussi vrai
pour l'industrie si j'ouvre une
parenthèse j'aurais dû peut-être le dire
en dans les propos liminaires si je
regarde l'industrie spatiale européenne
il y a à peu près 50% ou un peu plus de
50% qui aujourd'hui est en France donc
ça veut dire qu'on a quand même une
position de leadership toujours
aujourd'hui contestée on y reviendra
sans doute dans quelques instants
contester mais une position de
leadership en termes industriel qui est
qui reste qui reste aujourd'hui très
forte
donc gros effort gros efforts du
gouvernement de soutien de soutien au
spatial qui s'est traduit comme vous
l'avez vous l'avez indiqué par une
contribution une souscription française
de 3,2 milliards
d'euros de hausse de 20% à les arbres
donc c'est quelque chose de significatif
et avec un rééquilibrage de la
contribution française à lézard sur des
thématiques
pour dire les choses un petit peu
brutalement dans la précédente
ministérielle il fallait faire un effort
qui était un effort très important pour
finir le développement d'arène 6 alors
Ariane 6 n'a pas encore volé mais
l'effort budgétaire est plutôt j'ai
envie de dire derrière nous
on espère voilà et plutôt et derrière
nous donc il y avait eu une mobilisation
très forte sur les questions des
lanceurs et donc là on a ça nous a
permis cette nouvelle ministérielle a
permis à rééquilibrage en particulier
sur les questions d'observation de la
Terre qui sont absolument centrales et
où on a vraiment une position de de très
forte aujourd'hui et où on est revenu à
des budgets qui sont des budgets plus
importants si vous regardez
attentivement les chiffres il y a aussi
un effort qui est beaucoup plus
significatif que les années précédentes
sur l'exploration qui est moins liée à
une volonté politique de l'Instant T que
à une suite mécanique de décision qui
ont été prises précédemment puisque très
souvent quand on engage des programmes
ce sont des programmes qui qui se qui
s'étale sur
10 ou 15 ans et donc les engagements
passés très souvent évidemment sont
suivis derrière et donc les forces sur
l'exploration exploration
essentiellement robotique et
scientifique vient vient un peu en voilà
c'est la conclusion des ministériels
précédentes
je voudrais indiquer que alors
effectivement si on regarde stricto
sensu le périmètre résa la France et le
deuxième contributeur derrière
l'Allemagne et l'Italie avec des avec
quand même les trois pays qui sont dans
un mouchoir de poche enfin un peu de
choses près sur les sur les
contributions
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
il y a un choix aussi qui a un choix
aujourd'hui assumé je crois de de la
France d'avoir
une agence nationale qui est une agence
nationale forte avec aussi une un peu de
rééquilibrage aussi puisque il y a à
côté de la ministériel il y a aussi eu
la volonté d'abonder le budget du CNES
de 400 millions de 400 millions d'euros
à dans la trajectoire budgétaire pour
remonter un certain nombre de programmes
et puis de contribuer en même temps à
l'Agence spatiale européenne donc il
faut bien voir l'effort sur la somme de
de ces deux de ces deux contributions
alors peut-être un mot juste pour
éclairer et pour dire pourquoi justement
il y a cette volonté pouvoir cet
équilibrage parce que d'abord il y a un
certain nombre de programmes qu'on mène
par nature exclusivement dans le cadre
du CNES et pas dans le cadre de lézard
tous les programmes qui sont liés avec
des questions de sécurité des questions
de défense sont par nature exclues de de
lézard ça veut pas dire pour autant
qu'on est on les effectue pas dans des
cadres de collaboration bilatérales ou
multilatérales avec d'autres pays
européens mais c'est pas dans le cadre
de l'Agence spatiale européenne d'une
part et puis d'autre part il y a un
certain nombre de missions emblématiques
qu'on mène aujourd'hui de manière je
crois extrêmement efficace et
extrêmement visible avec nos grands
partenaires internationaux directement
c'est des missions la France est à bord
de toutes les missions martiennes de la
NASA comme vous voyez
il n'y a que la TV ici mais si vous
regardez les Rover martiens vous voyez à
chaque fois ils ont une espèce de tête
cette tête c'est une caméra qui permet à
la fois une caméra mais qui est surtout
dispositif permettant de permettant de
comprendre et de mesurer la composition
d'un certain nombre d'éléments qui sont
sur le sur le sol martien c'est des
cette caméra cette tête est faite à
Toulouse elle est faite elle est faite
par elle est faite en France les
publications vous avez pu voir récemment
si vous êtes intéressé au sujet sur la
structure interne de mars c'est-à-dire
comprendre en gros quelle était la
quelle était la structure géologique de
mars la taille du noyau etc c'est un
sismomètre qui a été fait là aussi en
France etc donc c'est plusieurs
coopérations extrêmement visibles c'est
aussi le satellite soit sur
l'observation de la Terre qui est un
satellite extraordinaire qui va
révolutionner la compréhension des des
échanges entre fin de la compréhension
de l'altimétrie et donc de la du niveau
des eaux de la mesure de la hauteur des
eaux et donc derrière qui va permettre
d'amener des mesures pour mieux
comprendre le climat aujourd'hui et les
évolutions du climat demain c'est un
truc extraordinaire qui a été fait
l'opération entre entre le CNES et la
NASA donc il y a voilà et puis alors
j'ai parlé de nos partenariats
américains mais c'est aussi vrai avec
l'Inde c'est aussi vrai avec les Émirats
et c'est aussi vrai que le Japon qui
sont des partenaires extrêmement forts
et où je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a une
vraie vocation à continuer des relations
bilatérales qui sont qui sont qui sont
très importantes aussi bien
scientifiquement médicaux même des
enjeux économiques et diplomatiques qui
sont qui sont importants pardon j'ai été
un petit peu long sur ce sujet là mais
ça me semblait important de redonner de
redonner de redonner un périmètre global
si je reviens quelques instants sur sur
les conclusions de la mission de la de
de la de la ministérielle de l'ESA donc
on a les points les points importants
vous avez mentionné iris square qui est
le programme de
la constellation dite breton donc la
constellation la constellation en orbite
basse qui va permettre de faire des
télécoms sécurisés
pour pour l'Europe c'est un programme
sur lequel la France c'est beaucoup
engagée
on a on est aujourd'hui à la fin dans la
phase de constitution de consortium qui
ont été déposés il y a quelques il y a
quelques jours ou quelques ou quelques
jours donc évidemment on espère que tout
ça va aller au bout il y a une
contribution importante française qui
est en leadership sur le sujet
important aussi de mentionner que
évidemment on a financé la transition
Ariane 5 aérienne 6
on a financé aussi la modernisation de
la base de courroux alors j'y suis
évidemment particulièrement attaché
parce que
à la fois c'est l'histoire et puis on
est on est on est gestionnaire de la
base le CNES et donc et je pense que il
y avait eu beaucoup de retards qui
avaient été pris par l'Europe sur la
modernisation de la base la base enfin
il faut investir pour la rendre à la
fois à la fois
la question digitale numérique où on est
très en retard sur la base et puis aussi
sur des aspects autour de du
verdissement enfin je le terme j'aime
pas le terme mais mais mais aujourd'hui
la manière dont la base la manière dont
la base est conçue à la fois sur les
ressources énergétiques sur la manière
dont on produit les
ergols etc doit être repensé échangé et
il y a des décisions d'investissement
fort qui ont été prises lors de la
ministériel et donc ça c'est une très
bonne c'est une très bonne c'est une
très bonne nouvelle je pourrais aussi
mentionner le fait qu'un certain nombre
de missions scientifiques comme à
évoluce pour là aussi des questions
d'observation ont été ont été ont été
ont été mises en place
donc voilà il y a quand même plein de
décisions intéressantes
si je bascule maintenant sur un autre
point que vous avez mentionné dans dans
dans l'introduction ou dans vos
questions peut-être un petit point sur
les lanceurs et sur là où on en est
aujourd'hui
alors je c'est sans doute le point le
plus compliqué et le plus difficile de
l'Europe spatiale aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut pas oublier que on a enfin
l'espace ne se réduit pas au lanceur
c'est évidemment très visible et c'est
là c'est sur ces programmes-là qu'on a
le plus de difficultés en Europe et
c'est aussi là-dessus que l'Europe
spatiale se déchire par moment c'est
essentiellement sur cette question des
lanceurs
on est passé en quelques mois en un peu
plus d'un an d'une situation où on avait
trois lanceurs disponibles à partir de
Kuru à une situation où aujourd'hui il
nous reste un lancement d'Ariane 5 à
faire et après on a plus de lanceur donc
c'est évidemment une situation de crise
parce que ça veut dire que derrière il y
a la question de l'accès à l'espace qui
est pour l'Europe et pour nos missions
institutionnelles cœur qui est
aujourd'hui menacé les raisons c'est
quoi c'est évidemment Soyouz et c'est
sans doute le point le plus compliqué
pour nous parce que la plupart de nos
lancements institutionnels européens
était sur Soyouz ils étaient pas sur
Ariane 5 ils étaient sur Soyouz Ariane 5
fait essentiellement pas que mais enfin
essentiellement essentiellement des
lancements ces dernières années des
lancements commerciaux de gros
satellites en orbite au stationnaire
bon et donc Soyouz était très très très
utile
il avait bien été prévu car il se
remplace Soyouz et Ariane 5 mais pas
dans le calendrier évidemment voilà
donc le départ des Russes de de courroux
nous a posé mécaniquement un vrai
problème d'autre part évidemment échec
de vegacé c'est le troisième échec de
Vega sur les sur les 8 ou 9 derniers
tirs donc évidemment ça pose un certain
nombre de questions on travaille dessus
vraiment le plus étroitement possible
avec l'industriel et puis avec les apps
pour essayer de trouver des solutions et
pour revenir en vol le plus rapidement
possible je suis relativement optimiste
ça va arriver ça va ça devrait arriver
assez vite mais enfin c'est quand même
une difficulté et puis Ariane 6 qui a
pris du retard donc Ariane 6 oui a pris
du retard à dépasser des en termes de
coûts et de délais c'est c'est évident
pour autant
j'ai pu être de temps en temps un peu
dur sur cette sur ce sujet là je dois
dire que les trois ou quatre derniers
mois qui se sont écoulés sont des mois
qui ou les difficultés plusieurs des
grandes difficultés techniques du
programme ont été résolus ou quasi
résolu
ça veut pas dire qu'il en reste pas ça
veut pas dire qu'on va pas en découvrir
d'autres mais il y a une bonne dynamique
qui a eu ces trois quatre derniers mois
donc pour être concret aussi bien sur le
pas de tir sous la responsabilité du
CNES que sur que sur le lanceur sous la
responsabilité d'Ariane groupe un
certain nombre des difficultés
techniques ont été levées et on n'a pas
perdu de et le planning a été tenu ces
derniers mois ce qui est ce qui n'a pas
été le cas précédemment donc il y a des
signaux qui sont quand même des signaux
positifs et qui sont et qui mobilisent
qui permettent aussi de mobiliser et
donner une dynamique forte à l'ensemble
de l'équipe sur le sur le sur le
programme donc je plutôt relativement
relativement optimiste je ne serai pas
vous donner une une date de une date de
tir
mais mais je suis je suis assez
optimiste voilà donc je préfère pas vous
donner une date de tir pour une raison
simple c'est qu'en fait on a aujourd'hui
devant nous des ce qu'on appelle les
essais combinés c'est le moment où on
relie le lanceur et son bâtir et on leur
demande de travailler ensemble tant d'un
point de vue logiciel c'est qui parle
qui parle ensemble et qui se parlent
bien que d'un point de vue mécanique que
sur les fluides etc et c'est le moment
où on découvre où on peut découvrir des
problèmes
ou pas donc et c'est conçu pour ça donc
donc
vous jurez que on va voler je sais pas à
tel ou à tel moment alors que on a ces
incertitudes qui sont devant nous et
qu'on est en train de regarder ça ce
serait ce serait prendre des engagements
que je vois
et l'enjeu de réussir important
évidemment donc première priorité pour
pour la France aujourd'hui c'est de
réussir le premier vol d'Ariane 6 il
faut être très très clair c'est ça parce
que à la fois il y a une volonté une
pression mais que je prends dans un sens
positif une pression politique de
l'ensemble de l'Europe sur cette volonté
de retrouver un accès à l'espace le
autonome le plus rapidement possible
donc c'est bien notre priorité numéro 1
et je crois que c'est une priorité qui
est une priorité partagée par les autres
grands pays du spatial européen
deuxième priorité évidemment c'est
réussir la montée en cadence rien de si
c'est pas parce qu'on a réussi le
premier lancement d'abord on n'aura pas
complètement qualifié le lanceur il y
aura besoin de plusieurs lancements pour
ça et puis il faudra réussir la monter
en cadence industrielle c'est à dire que
entre faire un vol et en faire 9 ou 10
par an c'est pas la même histoire et
c'est voilà donc ça ça va être aussi un
enjeu qui va nous mobiliser sur
plusieurs sur plusieurs mois plusieurs
années et puis toujours sur Ariane 6 le
troisième enjeu c'est aussi faire ce
qu'on appelle le bloc 2 c'est à dire la
capacité à faire une Ariane 6 qui va
être qui va être qui va être capable de
réaliser des vols plus ambitieux encore
que celles qu'on a pour le moment et
donc ça là aussi et qui va en
particulier être capable de réaliser les
contrats qu'on a signé avec Amazon et
donc c'est c'est un enjeu qui est un
enjeu qui est un enjeu qui est important
à côté d'Ariane 6 sur les lanceurs
il s'est engagé en Europe une
compétition
sur les mini et micro lanceurs
je crois qu'on peut dire de manière
assez claire que c'est pas une
compétition qui a été engagée par par la
France et c'est une compétition qui a
été engagée à un niveau national on est
complètement en dehors des schémas Isa
donc c'est il y a eu des compléments
on peut y voir de vrais avantages c'est
à dire qu'effectivement le fait qu'il y
ait cette compétition ça veut dire qu'il
y a pluralité d'acteurs donc il va y
avoir aussi probablement une dynamique
un peu plus forte et plus de challenge
pour tous les acteurs y compris nos
propres nos propres champions
c'est des idées nouvelles qui arrivent
donc c'est tout ça et tout ça est très
intéressant après moi il me semble qu'il
est absolument fondamental que la France
s'engage aussi dans cette dans cette
compétition pas tant pour le marché qui
est représenté par les mini lanceurs qui
est un marché
très modeste c'est à dire qu'il va
représenter peut-être 10 ou 15% de
l'ensemble du marché des lanceurs mais
par contre c'est un moyen pour tous les
nouveaux acteurs de rentrer sur le
marché des lanceurs et donc d'apprendre
et de monter en gamme demain mais c'est
aussi un moyen de démontrer des
technologies et pour nous je crois
vraiment qu'en particulier sur la
question du réutilisable qui est une
technologie qui n'a pas été mise en
oeuvre par la par la France et par
l'Europe et je pense que c'est
probablement une erreur qui a été faite
précédemment il y a enfin il y a
quelques décennies voilà Maya enfin Maya
ou d'autres petits lanceurs de ce type
là nous permettrons de maîtriser
rapidement cette technologie
réutilisable et ça répond aussi à des
objectifs qui sont des objectifs
intéressants même si le marché est petit
c'est des lancements réactifs c'est
aussi des besoins qui peuvent être des
besoins qui peuvent être intéressants
pour les pour le ministère de la Défense
donc voilà je pense que c'est vraiment
un point important j'ai cité maya mais
c'est pas la seule il y a d'autres
startups qui sont aussi en train de se
développer en France sur le sujet et en
Europe on en accueillera sur le pas de
tir diamant CSG et puis on va soutenir
aussi un certain nombre d'autres
startups françaises qui veulent se
développer et qui veulent et qui veulent
et qui veulent proposer leurs services
c'est pas le secteur des lanceurs n'est
pas pour les startups le
enfin le modèle de la start-up et pas le
modèle le plus évident quand vous voulez
développer un lanceur pourquoi parce
qu'en fait c'est ce sont ce sont
vraiment des projets qui sont quand même
je vais dire même en étant très
optimiste on va dire plus ryannel
voilà et le pluriel le pluriel pouvant
se transformer en pluridicénales si on
parle de très gros lanceur
y compris dans tous les projets
existants même même même du côté même
même ou Atlantique Starship enfin
Starship ou le Falcon c'est des projets
qui ont été étudiés pendant travaillé
pendant très très longtemps et qui sont
très CAPEX enfin très capitaux intensif
un très très intense en investissement
en investissements et donc le modèle de
la start-up est pas forcément le plus
évident mais il y a des startups
aujourd'hui qui se lancent sur le sujet
et on les aidera on les aide déjà
aujourd'hui et on continuera on
continuera à les aider
ça me ça me permet de glisser peut-être
rapidement sur le sujet newspace
effectivement c'est une grande priorité
aujourd'hui pour pour la France on est
passé en quelques années d'un système où
il y avait quelques startups par an dans
le spatial qui était essentiellement des
startups technologiques qui étaient très
par le notre environnement par le par le
CNES le CNRS ou des acteurs
universitaires des observatoires qui
venaient qui venaient vraiment qui
poussait qu'il venait de la techno et
qu'on a créé et qu'on a poussé et on en
a fait d'ailleurs un certain nombre de
voilà de champion ou de aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui
français européen et on en est très fier
on en est très content
on est passé de ce monde là à un monde
aujourd'hui on voit une nouvelle
start-up qui se crée dans le domaine du
spatial par semaine
par semaine par semaine alors les choses
changent alors juste pour modérer un
tout petit peu mon enthousiasme il a
échappé à personne que l'argent devenait
cher en ce moment et donc ce ce cet
écosystème va probablement ce contracter
un peu dans les enfin il est en train de
se contracter en ce moment et ça devient
plus difficile mais quand même malgré
tout les ordres de grandeur restent ça
montre qu'il y a une appétence très
forte qu'est-ce qui change
fondamentalement c'est le fait que il y
a un cercle vertueux qui s'est engagé
dans le spatial ou en tout cas dans
certains morceaux du spatial il y a de
nouveaux entrepreneurs qui arrivent avec
de nouvelles idées de nouvelles façons
de faire qui viennent du monde du
digital du monde du numérique d'autres
secteurs ou de secteurs industriels qui
font de la qui sont en panne non pas
dans la dans la dans l'ordre mais dans
la petite série si je devais et ça ça
bouleverse un peu la manière de faire il
y a aussi des capitaux privés qui
arrivent et comme les coûts commenc ent
à baisser de manière significative
évidemment tout ça a un côté extrêmement
vertueux alors je tempère immédiatement
mon propos en disant que ce que je dis
là n'est pas valable uniformément dans
le monde du spatial
c'est à dire que quand vous allez faire
un sismomètre sur Mars
le marché le marché pour les startups
est relativement
relativement étroit c'est pas demain
matin que on va avoir un changement
complet de l'écosystème autour de ça
par contre quand on parle de l'orbite
basse et qu'on parle de télécom quand on
parle de l'orbite basse et qu'on parle
de constellation de mini satellite ben
oui il y a des changements très profonds
parce que ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on
peut imaginer des constellations
d'haïotis en orbite basse pour
quelques millions ou dizaines de
millions d'euros alors qu'avant quand on
parlait de grands satellites
géostationnaires les investissements se
chiffraient en centaines de millions
d'euros donc c'est autre chose on est
sur un autre un autre schéma et donc ça
fait bouillonner cette écosystème et
donc évidemment il faut qu'on soit là
pour soutenir l'écosystème français pour
l'alimenter et le but du jeu étant
évidemment pas non plus de jeter aux
orties nos champions historiques qui
sont je rappelle quand même les trois
grands prêts européens
sont très
c'est franco-italien Airbus
une empreinte franco-allemande qui est
très forte et puis Ariane groupe a quand
même une empreinte française qui est
aussi et quand même très fort donc les
trois grands primes ont une présence
très très forte en France et donc
évidemment on doit à la fois continuer à
les soutenir mais il faut aussi qu'on
développe cet écosystème qui est source
d'opportunités de développement
économique majeur donc vraiment c'est
une priorité donc on a France 2030 avec
quand même beaucoup d'argent qui est
disponible pour les soutenir à travers
en particulier de l'achat de service
c'est-à-dire je pense que ça c'est très
très important et puis à côté de ça on a
aussi préparé au sein du CNES construit
au sein du CNES tout un ensemble de
dispositifs qui vont de l'idéation à des
fonds capables de les soutenir avec
aussi des de l'accélération des
incubateurs alors soit en national soit
en franco-allemand soit en européen on a
on a mis en a mis en place tout un
ensemble de dispositifs qui sont là
normalement pour les soutenir et pour
les aider et qui fonctionne à plein
régime alors on pourrait toujours dire
que il y en a pas assez et qu'il en faut
plus etc
genre j'entends bien mais mais il est là
notre enjeu aussi c'est regarder comment
est-ce qu'on met à disposition de ces
entreprises qui se créent ces
entrepreneurs le savoir-faire technique
de la maison CNES qui est qui est très
très fort qui est qui est incroyable
c'est aussi une petite révolution
culturelle parce que c'est pas comme ça
que que c'est pas notre mode
d'intervention naturel c'est pas comme
ça qui a été conçu voilà donc il y a
aussi beaucoup de changements internes à
mener mais je crois que ça je crois que
ça se fait une polype nous progressons
sur le sur une progression sur le sujet
je veux pas être trop longue
interrompez-moi si je si je suis si je
suis trop long bon
on a parlé on a parlé je voudrais
peut-être évoquer la question de
l'observation de la Terre et puis de
l'exploration
l'observation de la Terre est un enjeu
majeur bon d'abord l'Europe est très
bien placé
je crois qu'il y a une forme de dans une
Europe du spatiale qui est si je devais
être pudique je veux dire qui est
parfois un peu divisé
la question de l'observation de la Terre
est une question qui est qui je crois
fait consensus aujourd'hui en Europe
d'abord parce qu'on est bien placé d'un
point de vue industriel et puis parce
que ça répond à une préoccupation
majeure l'observation de la Terre avant
tout c'est pour les questions autour du
climat de la biodiversité du suivi d'un
certain nombre de polluants du suivi
enfin donc c'est juste quelque chose qui
est absolument fondamental et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'on continue à
être mobilisé
donc non seulement ça a fait l'objet
d'un effort particulier à la dernière
ministérielle de lesara mais je voudrais
aussi mentionner le fait j'ai mentionné
tout à l'heure le satellite SWOT qui est
quand même une
pèse mes mots une réussite technique
absolument exceptionnelle
l'administrateur de la NASA
le présenter comme le James web de
l'observation
et donc c'est c'est vraiment une
réussite technique incroyable entre
entre la France et les États-Unis ça va
révolutionner dans
une partie de la science des données
pour le climat mais aussi en termes de
d'impact économique il faut comprendre
qu'avec un instrument comme celui-là on
est capable de mesurer le niveau des
eaux y compris des eaux continentales
c'est-à-dire les fleuves les lacs
et les bassines
au risque au risque de de m'aventurer
sur un schéma il faudrait des très
grosses bassines parce qu'on a on a
quand même une un problème de résolution
géométrique mais
voilà
mais c'est derrière ça veut dire que
c'est une capacité à estimer simplement
avec un passage une fauchée de satellite
sur une centaine de kilomètres vous êtes
capable d'estimer d'un seul coup les
réserves en eau à l'instant T sur la
planète le long de cette fauché et donc
vous voyez bien aussi en termes d'impact
de suivi de politique publique de impact
économique aussi tout simplement je veux
dire que c'est juste majeur donc voilà
je voulais mentionner cette question
parce que ça me semble vraiment
fondamental et je crois vraiment qu'il
faut continuer à coopérer entre la
France et les États-Unis c'est la
coopération n'a jamais été aussi forte
sur ces sujets là il faut qu'on continue
exploration humaine et et la question de
l'exploration
le président de la République à Toulouse
en
septembre
il y a 18 mois voilà il y a 18 mois lors
du sommet spatial européen a demandé à
ce que cette question soit réouverte en
quelque sorte pourquoi je dirais ouverte
parce que l'Europe a fait le choix comme
je l'ai dit précédemment de rester à
côté de ces questions là
et donc de travailler systématiquement
sur le sur le vol habité de travailler
systématiquement avec des grands
partenaires alors historiquement je
qualifierai plus le grand partenaire
évidemment mais historiquement
évidemment avec la Russie puis après
avec les États-Unis et donc c'est
l'objet d'une coopération et donc on va
on fait voler nos astronautes sur l'ISS
avec des barteurs c'est à dire qu'on
amène des équipements en nature qui nous
permettent en échange de faire voler nos
astronautes sur l'ISF
pourquoi est-ce que cette question doit
être je crois réouverte aujourd'hui
la première des raisons c'est que
les coûts ont complètement changé la
Station spatiale internationale c'était
110 ou 120 milliards de dollars
d'investissement donc c'est considérable
et je pense pas que l'Europe serait en
voudrait ou souhaiterait faire ça demain
matin les nouveaux projets de station
spatiale privée qui sont développées
aujourd'hui par des entreprises
essentiellement aux États-Unis mais pas
que sont de l'ordre de quelques
milliards
c'est à dire qu'on voit des projets qui
arrivent ouais avec des projets de deux
ou trois milliards alors supposons que
ce sont des estimations très optimistes
parce que des coups mais enfin les
ordres de grandeur n'ont rien à voir et
donc autant cette question me semblait
exclure enfin ou en tout cas fermer le
sujet pour l'Europe parce que les
investissements étaient sans doute trop
élevés etc autant je pense qu'elle doit
être revisitée à l'aune de ces nouveaux
investissements d'autre part on est dans
un schéma si on regarde ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis ou aujourd'hui des
industriels américains sont prêts à
financer les CAPEX etc à financer
l'investissement et à demander aux
agences derrière de louer
du temps d'astronaute pour envoyer faire
des manips c'est les agences mais c'est
aussi des entreprises qui vont faire de
la R&D dans l'espace en envoyant des
ingénieurs leurs ingénieurs faire des
manips dans l'espace c'est un nouveau
schéma
moi il me semble que aujourd'hui
on a deux options c'est la fin de l'ISS
la Station spatiale internationale
plutôt dans sa fin de vie donc on aura
deux options soit effectivement ou trois
options soit on décide de ne plus
envoyer d'astronautes et on fait une
croix sur les vols habités si on veut y
aller ça veut dire qu'il faudra faire
voler nos astronautes sur des stations
spatiales américaines privées pourquoi
pas mais qui demain ne voudront
probablement pas jouer le travail de fin
être sur un schéma que ce qui est celui
de l'ISS c'est à dire on sera pas sur
des barteurs on sera pas sur de l'apport
technique en échange de vol on sera sur
simplement vous voulez voler tant de
mois et bien ça va coûter tant de
centaines de millions d'euros
moi je me demande simplement si on
n'aurait pas intérêt simplement en
Europe avec nos grands industriels qui
sont aujourd'hui en Europe que ce soit
Airbus que ce soit Thalès que ce soit au
HB ou d'autres acteurs est-ce qu'on a
pas intérêt à mener en Europe le même
dialogue qui a été mené avec entre la
NASA et les industriels américains pour
avoir demain une station spatiale
européenne c'est je prends l'exemple de
la station spatiale mais je pense que
cette question là doit se poser aussi
pour un lanceur qui qui pourrait être un
Ariane 6 human rated c'est à dire comme
vous l'avez mentionné ça peut être ça
peut être suivi ou ça peut être d'autres
projets qui ou ont simplement on serait
capable de lancer nos astronautes de
Kourou là aussi les coûts sont des coûts
qui sont les estimations qu'on a pu
faire qui sont des estimations très
préliminaires montrent que les coûts oui
c'est de l'argent c'est beaucoup
d'argent on parle on parle sans doute de
quelque chose un milliard peut-être
quelque chose comme ça
c'est beaucoup d'argent c'est mais c'est
pas non plus des choses qui sont
incommensurables au niveau au niveau
européen je pense que ces questions
elles doivent être posées aujourd'hui et
je pense que pardon de dire les choses
brutalement mais je pense que oui
évidemment ces sujets là enfin avoir des
astronautes c'est important pour les
programmes scientifiques mais si vous
interrogez aujourd'hui les scientifiques
ils vous diront pas je vais le dire très
honnêtement ils vont pas que c'est leur
préoccupations numéro 1
c'est important pour faire de la R&D
pour les entreprises mais c'est aussi je
crois très très important pour l'image
que l'Europe veut porter aujourd'hui sur
le spatial mais pas que sur le spatial
sur sa confiance en l'avenir sur sa
confiance en la science sur sa confiance
en la technologie et sur simplement le
regarder l'image que Thomas Pesquet
projette aujourd'hui qui est une image
extraordinaire de confiance et aussi de
messages sur qui dépasse aussi le
spatial sur ce qu'est la terre
aujourd'hui sur sa fragilité et je pense
que l'Europe peut pas rester en dehors
de ça donc c'est voilà c'est mon
plaidoyer pour pour le pour le pour
l'exploration et pour le et pour le pour
le vol habité c'est des questions qui
aujourd'hui je pense sont encore
débattues tant au point de vue national
que en Europe et il n'y a pas de
consensus aujourd'hui en Europe qui est
en train de se questionner de voilà mais
je pense qu'il faut peut-être que la
résultante de tout ça sera plutôt un
choix pour conservateur disons que non
on veut pas y aller mais je pense de
toute façon qu'il faut poser cette
question là et c'est une question
politique c'est pas une question
technique c'est une question politique
je suis peut-être m'arrêter m'arrêter là
sur j'ai pas répondu à tous les sujets
vont sont nombreuses d'abord et puis bon
vous êtes peut-être reposé sous une
autre forme et j'en garde une en tête
que je vous reposerai si elle n'est pas
reposer tout à l'heure je vais donner la
parole à Anne Catherine loisirs ensuite
à Evelyne renaud-garabée
merci et merci Monsieur le le Président
c'est vrai que le spatial je pense que
c'est un sujet sur lequel on doit
davantage se familiariser nous les
parlementaires pour avoir participé il y
a quelques semaines pour la Commission à
c'était
u open inter parlementary space group
en fait j'étais la seule Française
bon voilà je crois qu'il y a un vrai
sujet pour le Parlement français
peut-être de s'emparer davantage de ces
grands enjeux que vous venez d'évoquer
ces enjeux de
d'abord de
redécouvert de toutes les opportunités
que peut présenter le spatial
aujourd'hui pour répondre aux grands
défaut de notre petite planète beaucoup
de réponses sont effectivement dans dans
l'espace et quand on discute avec les
acteurs économiques on ressent à ce que
vous dites cette cette dynamique s'est
effervescence je dirais qui est en train
de se développer avec des enjeux
d'observation vous l'avez bien dit sur
notamment
fait changement climatique alors vous
nous avez pas reparlé de de de de la
réussite aussi de Jul voilà donc
peut-être que vous nous en dire un mot
parce que ça c'est aussi un formidable
pour le coup c'est c'est du positif et
c'est c'est c'est quelque chose qui nous
projette dans dans l'avenir et dans des
perspectives vous avez beaucoup parlé du
du stratégie qu'avec les enjeux de
souveraineté télécommunications défense
[Musique]
nos contrats avec les Américains voilà
donc comment est-ce qu'on va lancer nos
satellites voilà si on veut tenir le
délai de 2027 puisque si j'ai bien
compris il y aura pas forcément de place
pour tout le monde dans les
constellations de satellite donc ce
serait bien que la constellation
européenne trop sa place rapidement
merci
très bien merci beaucoup Anne-Catherine
Evelyne Renaud garabée ensuite Serge
gabarit merci Madame présidente monsieur
le directeur général lorsque vous avez
pris vos fonctions en 2021 vous avez
clairement affiché votre attention de
faire de ce secteur spatial français
européen l'un de vos futurs enjeux
stratégiques
en décembre 2022 le satellite sfot qui
comme vous l'avez indiqué tout à l'heure
et le symbole de la coopération
franco-américaine a été lancé pour
collecter les informations sur la
manière dont l'océan influence le
changement climatique j'ai deux petites
questions à vous poser pouvez-vous nous
indiquer comment se déroule cette
coopération entre la NASA et le CNES et
quels sont vos premières observations
sur cette mission qui va se terminer
d'ici le mois de septembre 2023 merci de
vous répondre
merci Evelyne Serge babary ensuite
Bernard but
merci Madame la président monsieur le
Président merci tout d'abord pour vos
propos enthousiasmants et qui balise les
développements attendus j'aurais évoqué
quelque chose qui peut sembler négatif
c'est la problématique des débris
les débrises spatiaux le nombre la masse
la superficie de ces objets augmentent
régulièrement et cela augmente le risque
qu'il pose au satellite en activité et à
toute autre activité d'ailleurs spatiale
le bureau des débris spéciaux spatiaux
de lézard surveillent en permanence
cette situation en constante évolution
et dites des normes des réglementations
pour une utilisation durable de l'espace
en fait
volonté d'atténuer le nombre de débris
quel est votre réflexion sur ce sujet
important quel est éventuellement les
actions que vous menez pour assurer une
durabilité des des objets qui sont
envoyés dans l'espace merci
merci monsieur le Président Bernard buis
ensuite Micheline Jack merci présidente
monsieur le Président merci pour vos
propos introductifs j'ai deux questions
dans son rapport publié le 4 mai dernier
la Cour des comptes soulève les
difficultés relatives au maintien en
interne des compétences techniques
compte tenues du vieillissement actuel
des effectifs du CNES 33% des effectifs
aurait atteignent l'âge de 62 ans d'ici
2025 et du manque de renouvellement des
ingénieurs la Cour des comptes vous
suggère de mener à son terme
l'identification des compétences
prioritaires dans le cadre d'une gestion
prévisionnelle des emplois et
compétences face aux enjeux à venir en
matière de politique spatiale comment
assurer le renouvellement des ingénieurs
au sein du CNES la deuxième question
comme vous l'avez indiqué la stratégie
du fitness a évolué alors que les modes
d'action étaient centrés sur la conduite
de bout en bout de projet complexes ils
sont aujourd'hui orientés vers
l'accompagnement des entreprises petites
et grandes publiques ou privée et des
start-up innovantes raison pour laquelle
vous avez pensé la mise en place de
nouvelles sources de financement telles
que le fond cosmique capital voué
accompagner une vingtaine d'entreprises
européennes de l'économie spatiale et le
fort spacefender programme public créé
en 2021 pour accélérer le développement
des startups
entrepreneurial français dans le secteur
spatial merci merci beaucoup Bernard
michelinja ensuite Jean-Pierre manga
merci président de chers collègues
monsieur le Président merci pour vos
informations très éclairantes j'ai eu la
chance de visiter le Centre Spatial le
Kourou et j'avoue que c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'extraordinaire à faire
pour aller dans le droit fil de mon
collègue Bernard buis
je ferai référence aux observations de
définitive de la Cour des comptes qui
signale un écart des écarts de salaire
significatif entre le CNES et
l'industrie pour une même le taux de
turnover des moins de 35 ans est
supérieur à 24% donc la Cour des comptes
préconise une politique d'attractivité
du CNES sur ses atouts propres outre le
suivi de projet et la veille au respect
de des cahiers des charges le
développement d'une politique
privilégiant l'impulsion de l'innovation
interne sans peur de l'échec peut-être
infléchir ce turnover et j'aurai une
deuxième question sur la Guyane
justement la maîtrise de l'accès à
l'espace comme vous l'avez
justement indiqué c'est un élément
essentiel pour embrasser toutes les
nouvelles thématiques du secteur spatial
tel que l'Observatoire du climat
exploration l'action dans l'espace et
les méga constellations face à la montée
en puissance des grands industriels du
secteur notamment Ariane groupe sur les
lanceurs Loch Ness ayant rendu sépare du
capital d'Ariane groupe motivé par la
compétitivité de l'accès à l'espace la
France ne risque-t-elle pas de perdre la
maîtrise du Centre spatial de Guyane
merci Micheline Jean-Pierre Moguet
ensuite Daniel salon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président merci
pour pour vos propos j'avais une
première question sur la contribution
les âmes et vous avez largement répondu
donc je ne vous la pose pas par contre
quels sont pour vous les les enjeux
budgétaires les plus importants pour le
prochain le prochain PLF et puis j'ai
une deuxième question que vous l'avez un
peu abordé qui concerne le les startups
et le et le tourisme spatial il y a une
société qui s'appelle
zefalto qui propose des voyages autour
de la Terre et un dîner notamment à
120.000 euros apparemment
ce projet et se fait avec vous est-ce
que vous pouvez est-ce que vous pouvez
nous en dire de mots je n'ai pas retenu
de place pour ce pour ce voyage je vous
le dispositif est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire deux mots sur ce type de
projet les avantages que ça peut
présenter aussi être financièrement je
ne sais pas je vous remercie Président
si on peut faire une mission
Jean-Pierre Daniel salmon suite Daniel
Gremillet
président merci monsieur le Président
pour votre présentation je voulais vous
poser une question sur l'intérêt des
vols habités à l'heure de l'intelligence
artificielle et de la robotique vous
avez fait tout de suite un plaidoyer
sans emballage donc je comprends bien
votre vision de ces volats et plus le
caractère symbolique et de porter de
portée politique je voulais également
poser une question sur l'encombrement de
l'espace et des déchets mais mon
collègue Serge barbarie a déjà posé la
question donc
j'attendrai votre réponse à ce niveau là
c'est une des pollution une autre
dépollution c'est une pollution
lumineuse des constellations qui n'est
pas sans poser problème puisque un des
derniers paysages gratuits aujourd'hui
c'est bien le cosmos et donc il faudrait
voir enfin j'attends d'avoir un petit
peu votre éclairage sur la capacité
demain à avoir des satellites qui ne
renvoie pas la lumière je crois qu'il y
a des recherches dans ce sens là donc
j'aimerais bien vous entendre sur sur le
sujet et puis sinon vous avez abordé
l'observation de la Terre je pense que
c'est vraiment fondamental aussi bien on
pense au climat mais je pense que
l'observation va nous apporter des
éclairages sur les évolutions au niveau
de la vie sur terre et au niveau des la
végétation mais aussi bien terrestre que
sur les mers donc je pense que là nous
avons besoin absolument de la recherche
merci
et merci président
de chers collègues effectivement cette
répressionnant et j'aurais trois
questions la première question c'est
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pouvez nous
donner un peu une photographie entre ce
qui se passe au dessus à des fins
militaires à des fins économiques à des
fins touristiques enfin touristiques
vous avez compris le message
deuxième question je voudrais pas
j'aurais prolonger la question de serre
j'ai effectivement où en étant dans
l'organisation du gendarme de l'espace
en dehors de la question de la gestion
de récupérer ce qui n'est plus utilisé
etc il y a-t-il un gendarme et comment
évolue effectivement cette organisation
du gendarme de l'espace et ma dernière
question c'est quel sera le carburant du
futur du spatial
c'est une petite question
Franck montoget
merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur pour votre présentation lors de
votre audition initiale je vous avais
interrogé sur la question du droit de
l'espace je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez donc je voudrais savoir
les sujets importants à un jeu
aujourd'hui selon vous en matière de
droit de l'espace
je voudrais aussi
comprendre
comment
l'Agence spatiale européenne et et notre
pays
se positionne dans la gouvernance
justement du droit
du droit du droit de l'espace
[Musique]
voilà parce que c'est cette
c'est un domaine qui me paraît assez
nébuleux on constate que
voilà la question de l'utilisation
durable de l'espace
voilà et majeur qu'on est en train un
petit peu de le saccager si j'ai si j'ai
bien compris
donc je pense que c'est entre autres un
sujet de législation
tout à fait tout à fait important voilà
et question subi hier en matière de
réchauffement climatique
est-ce qu'il a été fait mesure
de l'impact
de ce qui se fait en matière de
la matière d'espace d'utilisation de
l'espace et de lancement en particulier
est-ce qu'il y a des au niveau des des
motorisations etc est-ce qu'il y a des
choses qui qui vont dans le bon sens à
cet égard merci
personne ne demande plus la parole donc
je vais juste rajouter deux deux petites
questions une que je vous avais pas posé
quel est l'impact en fait du retrait du
Royaume-Uni de l'Union européenne sur
les programmes spatiaux parce que il y a
un impact dans la coopération dans la
contribution
industrielle financière etc première
question et deuxième question que je
vous repose qui est la dernière je vous
avais posé dans le dans le préalable
avez-vous des nouvelles de la mise à
jour de la loi de juin 2008 sur les
opérations spatiales qui doit être
relancé qui devrait être au calendrier
dans les dans les mois ou dans les
années qui viennent
merci merci beaucoup pour ces questions
nombreuses
peut-être dans le désordre peut-être
commencer par la question des des débris
spatiaux et et derrière aussi la
question des de du cadre enfin des
cadres législatifs et réglementaires qui
qui peuvent s'imposer
donc on a effectivement il y a un
certain nombre d'orbites qui deviennent
qui deviennent encombrés en particulier
l'orbite basse qui concentre énormément
de lancement aujourd'hui la situation
est un peu différente sur les orbites
géostationnaires ou pour le coup on est
quand même sur des bons
donc il y a des risques potentiels de
collision il y a eu quelques il y a eu
effectivement quelques collisions dans
le passé avec la génération de débris il
y a aussi eu mais ça c'est un autre
sujet des destructions volontaires d'un
certain nombre de satellites avec des
avec des missiles en particulier qui ont
généré beaucoup de débris sur ces
orbites sur ces orbites basses mais donc
il y a un sujet de d'encombrement il y a
un sujet d'encombrement de l'orbite et
puis il y a un sujet simplement de
régulation du trafic entre guillemets
on est
pas du tout au niveau d'organisation
que qu'on peut avoir dans le monde
aérien ou y compris dans les pays des
pays
avec tous les pays du monde il y a un
nombre de règles commune minimales qui
permettent de réguler le trafic on n'est
pas dans cette configuration là
aujourd'hui dans le spatial il y a un
certain nombre de choses qui se font de
manière quand même très très artisanale
c'est-à-dire quand vous voyez deux
satellites qui se qui sont
potentiellement sur une course de
collision
quel est l'enjeu en général les
opérateurs le savent le détecte et après
il faut savoir qu'il va bouger
et pourquoi c'est important quelque
chose qui est important parce qu'en fait
pour bouger vous
pardon
voilà le problème c'est qu'en fait vous
dépensez du carburant
et donc ça veut dire que c'est la durée
de vie de votre satellite que vous que
vous que vous que vous entamez si vous
faites un mouvement donc ça fait l'objet
de discussion parfois surprenante entre
les différents opérateurs donc on voit
bien qu'on est dans une mécanique
aujourd'hui qui est pas du tout une
mécanique
industriel ou sans fin la régulation la
régulation la régulation n'est pas là
pour le trafic et puis après il y a la
question de la gestion du de la gestion
des débits et de la désorbitation
aujourd'hui on a un certain nombre
d'opérateurs internationaux qui sont pas
dans une logique de recherche de enfin
logique de responsabilité et qui envoie
des satellites sans chercher simplement
à mettre en oeuvre des mécanismes des
orbitations en fin de vie pourquoi parce
qu'en fait utiliser du carburant en fin
de vie pour désorbiter un satellite et
le faire brûler dans l'atmosphère ça
veut dire que vous allez utiliser 15% du
carburant pour ça et donc c'est la durée
de vie de votre satellite et derrière
évidemment le rendement économique ou
même scientifique ou défense qui va être
d'autant d'autant réduit
donc le la France est donc l'Europe
puisque derrière c'est la lost la loi
spatiale
s'applique aux opérateurs qui partent de
courroux donc ça veut dire que il y a un
impact qui est quand même très très fort
sur et quand même assez en avance sur
sur son temps là-dessus puisque on
impose un certain nombre de contraintes
aux opérateurs qui lancent à partir de à
partir de Kourou donc on est plutôt on
est plutôt on est plutôt en avance ça ne
règle pas évidemment l'ensemble du
l'ensemble du sujet le la question qui a
été posée qui était de se dire en fait
dans quel cadre il faut le faire
on a un cadre national évident avec
l'impact du fait que le port spatial
européen est situé en France donc ça
veut dire qu'on a évidemment
le cadre le cadre législatif français
important après les discussions qu'on
peut avoir au sein de lézard sont des
discussions qui sont intéressantes mais
les ânes n'a pas de n'a pas de vecteurs
normatif ou législatif donc ça veut dire
que derrière ces lieux qui doit prendre
la main et lieu à à émi un certain
nombre de signaux récemment disons que
c'était des sujets qui étaient qui
commençaient à l'intéresser
véritablement de manière générale la
commission s'intéresse de plus en plus
au spatial et je crois d'ailleurs très
profondément que toute une partie de
l'avenir du spatial européen passe par
passe par une implication plus forte de
la Commission européenne en particulier
sur ces sur ces sujets là et donc je
pense qu'il faut qu'elle ait discussions
entre en particulier enfin avec tous les
états tous les états de lieu mais la
France a sans doute un message
particulier à faire passer parce qu'on a
une expérience sur le sujet qui est une
expérience assez large mais enfin le
vrai problème il est pas là le vrai
problème c'est que si vous voulez avoir
un minimum de règles communes ça veut
dire qu'il faut mettre autour de la
table aujourd'hui toutes les puissances
spatiales internationales pour avoir un
cadre de discussion
c'est encore une autre voilà c'est
encore c'est encore c'est encore une
autre histoire alors je suis
relativement optimiste parce que je
pense que c'est l'intérêt de tous de le
faire mais ce cadre là aujourd'hui est
probablement un cadre autour des Nations
Unies donc on va avoir un certain nombre
de de régulation et de dispositif commun
mais pour l'instant on n'en est pas tout
à fait là
c'est les rapports de force et puis
c'est
aujourd'hui
je sais pas dans quel instant on peut
parler de ce cadre là entre des
puissances comme la Chine et les
États-Unis par exemple
donc c'est un problème qui n'est pas qui
n'appelle pas de réponse il y a pas de
travail il y a pas de réponse triviale
ou simple à cette question là c'est un
enjeu majeur c'est un enjeu pour tout le
monde donc c'est le le côté enfin la
dimension l'espoir entre c'est simple
c'est que tout le monde il y a un
intérêt c'est à dire que que vous soyez
chinois indien européen ou
nord-américain on a tous intérêt à
trouver un cadre minimal de
de régulation pour pour cette orbite
pour cette orbite basse mais on n'y est
pas alors à côté de ce à côté de ce
constat là il y a aussi un certain
nombre d'initiatives qui sont prises
aujourd'hui pour
désorbiter des des satellites qui sont
des satellites inactifs
alors d'abord je voudrais mentionner le
fait que c'est évidemment intéressant ça
va quand même coûter très très cher
chaque des orbitations
donc on est quand même aujourd'hui
plutôt dans dans des démonstrateurs dans
la R&D
je vous alerte aussi sur le fait que
entre désorbité un satellite qui est
inactif et désorbitée un satellite non
coopératif pour des enjeux de défense ou
de
[Musique]
bon c'est pas très très loin donc c'est
probablement aussi une des un des un des
une des raisons de l'engouement qu'il
peut y avoir aujourd'hui sur ce sur ces
questions là c'est je pense pas qu'on va
régler le problème des débris
aujourd'hui simplement en allant mettre
en place des solutions désorbitaces
spécifiques parce que ça va être ça va
être compliqué
à terme il y a aussi pardon j'en ai pas
du tout parlé mais il y a aussi à terme
d'autres modèles qui sont des modèles
plus pérennes qu'on pourrait imaginer
dans l'espace puisque aujourd'hui les
satellites ont une durée de vie qui est
limitée par leur les
ergols qui vont emmener ou leur ou leur
propulseurs enfin
demain avec des mécanismes de rifioling
en orbite on peut aussi imaginer des des
systèmes qui sont là pour beaucoup plus
longtemps et donc qui ont des durées de
vie plus longues ça ne règle pas non
plus tous les sujets mais c'est aussi ce
serait aussi une contribution à cette
question là le
[Musique]
pour le
vous parlez de rifioling donc j'entends
bien mais je comprends à quoi ça sert
évidemment pour pour changer d'orbite
etc
en fait vous avez besoin un satellite en
particulier pour maintenir le maintenir
d'accord donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
système
en fait le vous n'êtes jamais dans un
dans un vide comme ça il y a toujours
quelques parties les frottements etc qui
font que ils sont très faibles mais donc
qui tendent mécaniquement à réduire la
vitesse
à le faire et donc vous avez besoin de
les maintenir un poste régulièrement en
particulier en orbite basse et donc de
systématiquement les remettre à niveau
alors vous avez pour ça soit de la
propulsion chimique avec des ergols
ça c'est la méthode la plus ancienne la
plus traditionnelle ou autrement autre
solution c'est des c'est de la
propulsion électrique avec des donc des
panneaux solaires et de la propulsion
électrique mais enfin cette propulsion
est électrique mais elle n'est pas non
plus infinie parce que c'est enfin vous
utilisez malgré tout soit de l'iode soit
des choses comme ça pour simplement vous
voulez consommer donc ça veut dire
qu'ils sont pas une durée de vie infinie
non plus donc dans les deux cas on a les
durédit qui sont des durées de vie qui
sont limitées
on parlait peut-être
si je fais je réponds j'essaye peut-être
de répondre sur la sur la les enjeux
autour de
possible modification de la Loos des
enjeux de court terme qui sont vraiment
urgents pour nous c'est des
modifications de la Losse qui permet de
permettre de prendre en compte
efficacement la question des
constellations donc comment est-ce qu'on
gère des constellations de satellites
c'est-à-dire tout ça a été conçu dans un
cadre où on lançait un satellite pour
une mission là on a des constellations
de satellites et puis aussi toute la
question du réutilisable ça veut dire
comment est-ce qu'on fait demain pour
travailler sur un lanceur qui va revenir
c'est pas le cadre initial qui a été
pensé par le législateur était pas
évidemment un cadre où on avait de la
réutilisabilité donc ça ce sont deux des
enjeux qui sont des enjeux importants
pour le pour le pour le futur
vous avez mentionné aussi alors si je
m'éloigne un petit peu des débris
spatiaux et si je viens sur les
questions autour de l'impact des de
l'industrie spatiale et de nos activités
alors je pense qu'on a on a une comme
toute activité
économique industrielle scientifique
technique etc on a on a évidemment une
une responsabilité environnementale
qui commence par avoir des bâtiments qui
sont dans des normes qui sont à peu près
respectables voilà ce qui est ce qui
pour nous un immense en jeu sur sur
l'immobilier en particulier en Guyane
mais c'est ça c'est avoir des énergies
qui sont des énergies les plus
décarbonées possible sur nos sites etc
après il y a le l'impact du lancement
même je reviendrai peut-être sur ces
deux points juste après mais il y a
l'impact du lancement même et c'est vrai
que ça peut être très impressionnant
vous voyez un lanceur qui part c'est bon
c'est
je de mémoire et je vérifierai le la
comparaison mais de mémoire l'ensemble
des lancements mondiaux aujourd'hui
représente quelques heures de trafic
aérien international
[Musique]
en fait les c'est un gaz à effet de
serre qui est considérable et donc
l'impact n'est pas forcément enfin
produire de l'eau n'est pas forcément
mieux que de produire du CO2 sur sur ces
sujets là donc c'est voilà il faut bien
avoir le sujet complètement en tête
parce que on n'est pas sur on n'est pas
dans l'atmosphère donc ça veut dire que
voilà donc c'est pas forcément non plus
c'est pas non plus idéal donc cette
question là est pas complètement pas
complètement tranchée je voudrais
insister sur le j'ai mentionné le sujet
énergie et immobilier en particulier en
Guyane là-bas spatiale et vieillissante
on a un enjeu immobilier c'est à dire
que
on a des bâtiments qui sont des
bâtiments qui sont vieux qui sont
évidemment climatisés parce que voilà il
suffit d'aller en Guy hâte
donc ils sont qui sont évidemment qui
sont évidemment climatisés donc on a un
enjeu de rénovation on a un enjeu aussi
autour de production électrique qui soit
une production électrique la plus
décarbonée possible il faut avoir en
tête que aujourd'hui contenu de la
qualité du réseau en Guyane quand on est
à proximité du lancement notre source
nominale de d'énergie ce sont des
groupes électrogènes diesel du site avec
donc ça veut dire que donc on a on a
envie de remplacer ça par un système
avec évidemment du photovoltaïque et des
et du stockage batterie
c'est pas si je dois émettre une toute
petite plainte c'est pas le c'est pas
facile d'obtenir les autorisations
nécessaires pour environnemental et
c'est compliqué c'est
compliqué mais je ferme ce
on va y arriver mais c'est compliqué
voilà bon
et puis on a aussi un enjeu de
production d'hydrogène vert ou là aussi
on est très motivé et on a un certain
nombre de de projets en particulier
d'utiliser de la biomasse pour faire de
l'hydrogène vert plutôt que d'utiliser
de l'hydrogène gris qui est produit
aujourd'hui les produits aujourd'hui
donc voilà ça c'est des quelques-uns des
enjeux RSE de du CNES et de la et de la
Guyane on en a aussi évidemment à
Toulouse dans l'amélioration voilà mais
on a une autre responsabilité classique
de d'industriel et puis évidemment je
pense qu'on a aussi un devoir
d'exemplarité parce que on travaille
aussi et on met beaucoup en avant on
travaille beaucoup sur les questions
autour du climat et autour de
l'observation de la Terre et donc je
pense que à ce titre là on a un devoir
d'exemplarité
parti on a
eu un mot aussi sur le tourisme spatial
[Musique]
alors le tourisme spatial est un sujet
qui est très qui est beaucoup mis en
avant ou Atlantique et un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui qui veulent se lancer
dans le spatial utilise le tourisme
spatial pour financer une partie de
leurs activités
je serai surpris enfin c'est pas
évidemment au CNES de décréter ce qui
est possible ou pas possible dans ce
secteur là mais je serai quand même
surpris que en Europe
on est un développement
identique j'ai pas l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui l'opinion publique
européenne serait prête à envoyer demain
des astronautes faire du tourisme
spatial bon en tout cas ça me semble pas
être le chemin qui est pris le projet
qui a été le projet qui a été mentionné
zefalto
pour le coup est un projet qui a un
projet alors c'est falto est un projet
sur des ballons
c'est pas du on mais c'est pas des gens
qui vont donc on va on va battre je
pense qu'ils doivent être à 20 ou à 30
voilà 20 ou 30 km donc enfin c'est
relativement bas enfin c'est ce qui vous
permet quand même d'avoir une expérience
du du noir de l'espace donc vous avez
l'impression d'être dans l'espace vous
n'y êtes pas mais vous avez l'impression
d'être dans l'espace je me prononcerai
pas sur la qualité du déjeuner qui est
servi je je voilà
les ballons parce que par contre ce que
je ce que je défendrai dans le pro parce
que ce que je défendrai dans le projet
c'est que
pour le coup les ballons ont un impact
environnemental qui est un impact très
très très maîtrisé c'est c'est on n'est
pas du tout dans la même logique que une
logique de de quelqu'un dans une capsule
et on le met sur un lanceur c'est un
ballon c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement réutilisé c'est normalement
un impact environnemental très très très
modeste et très très faible
c'est d'ailleurs les ballons et je pense
d'ailleurs qu'il y a eu une audition je
pouvais pas m'y rendre mais sur les
ballons c'est un des c'est une des une
des branches d'activités du CNES même si
on volume en budget c'est relaté c'est
très modeste par rapport aux autres
activités mais c'est tout le charme
justement des ballons c'est que non
seulement ça a un impact environnemental
faible c'est aussi réutilisable c'est à
dire que la charge utile que vous
envoyez si vous envoyez pas des hommes
mais si vous envoyez une charge utile ce
qu'on fait nous aujourd'hui très
régulièrement c'est des charges utiles
que vous récupérez donc ça veut dire que
les données vous les récupérez
immédiatement vous récupérez les
instruments vous pouvez changer la manip
repartir donc pour les scientifiques
c'est très très intéressant et c'est pas
cher ça ne coûte sur ça coûte très très
enfin c'est très très modeste comme
infrastructure c'est compliqué à faire
mais c'est pas très très cher et donc
c'est vraiment très intéressant il y a
plein de choses qu'on peut faire avec
des ballons et on n'a pas besoin d'aller
avec sur un lanceur pour faire ça et
puis ça nous est utile aussi pour
calibrer tout un ensemble d'instruments
c'est aussi très utile pour les sujets
de défense et on voit aujourd'hui les
les ministres les différents ministères
de chargés de la défense en partout dans
le monde s'intéresser de plus en plus au
ballon et vous avez tous en tête
évidemment l'épisode chinois
les États-Unis donc voilà donc j'ai
falto est une enfin je sais pas moi non
plus de faire de la publicité pour une
entreprise ou pour une autre d'ailleurs
il y en a d'autres il y a d'autres
entreprises qui sont qui sont sur le
même secteur aujourd'hui en France et je
trouve que c'est quelque chose qui a
dissocié du tourisme spatial en général
c'est pas tout à fait la même approche
j'ai pas parlé de juice et j'ai pas
parlé du JWST j'ai pas parlé on a de
très très beaux projets européens
effectivement il y a eu de lancement il
y a quelques mois il y a un mois à peu
près un mois un mois et demi de voilà de
de juice qui est une mission de l'Agence
spatiale européenne qui est une mission
absolument incroyable qui montre là
vraiment tout ce que l'Europe peut faire
de bien ou de très très bien quand on
arrive à travailler efficacement
ensemble c'est donc une très très belle
mission vers Jupiter qui va nous
permettre d'aller aussi regarder les
lunes glacées Jupiter et derrière la
question des lunes glacées ça veut dire
essayer aussi de voir si c'est l'une
était habitable habitable au sens Astro
enfin
pas humainement habitable évidemment
mais est-ce qu'il y a eu est-ce qu'elles
ont été est-ce qu'elles ont accueilli la
vie à un moment donné une forme de vie à
un moment ou un autre et on pourrait
avoir un certain nombre d'informations
intéressantes avec douce qui qui
nous enverra ces informations c'est
apprendre un petit peu de temps puisque
le trajet pour Jupiter c'est huit ans
c'est ça huit ans avec en plus une
mécanique spatiale assez fascinante
puisqu'on utilise des effets de fronde
donc ça veut dire que voilà c'est une
très très belle c'est une très très
belle mission
voilà et je croise les doigts le
lancement a été sans problème le
lancement du je vais revenir 30 secondes
sur le James web télescope qui est une
incroyable mission ou à la fois comme
dans le juou c'est la France a fourni un
certain nombre des instruments mais il y
a aussi la question du lanceur
je sais que de temps en temps la
question nos partenaires européens ou
peuvent être parfois un peu taquin sur
la dualité d'Ariane groupe et sur le
fait que Ariane groupe fait à la fois un
lanceur mais aussi d'autres activités
pour la défense
je ne suis et moi je crois profondément
qu'il y a un intérêt évidemment très
fort d'avoir cette dualité dans les deux
sens
et les précisions d'injections qui sont
obtenues par un groupe aujourd'hui sur
ariansi sur arène 5
sur le JWST quand on entend aujourd'hui
la NASA nous dit redire publiquement que
grâce à la précision d'injection
d'Ariane 5 ils ont gagné 10 ans de vie
sur ce satellite qui a quand même coûté
10 milliards de dollars
complètement négligeable
d'assez lié aussi aux activités dual
dans un groupe
et donc ça il faut pas l'oublier
donc c'est utile mais c'est utile dans
les deux sens et donc je pense que c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'il faut qu'il
faut garder en tête et qu'il faut
probablement pérenniser
je vais peut-être un tout petit mot sur
la manière dont on travaille avec les
États-Unis sur
l'exemple de soi qui avait été qui avait
été pris
c'est une coopération alors en fait tous
les projets qui sont menés au clair sauf
quelques projets défense sont des
projets qui sont menés en bilatérale ou
en multilatérale donc c'est toujours une
coopération donc ça veut dire qu'on se
met d'accord auparavant avec une en
général avec une autre agence pour dire
ben voilà on va faire telle satellite
toi tu vas amener la plateforme moi je
vais amener tel instrument
éventuellement telle autre agence va
amener telle autre instant et puis telle
personne va être en charge de
l'intégration de tout ça et puis après
on lance et puis à la question du
segment sur donc il y a une répartition
des rôles évidemment bien avant
sur sur soi la France était responsable
d'une partie d'une partie des
instruments et de la plateforme
ça a été et c'est une coopération qui
est une coopération très très fluide
entre aujourd'hui entre entre nos amis
américains et le CNES donc ça veut dire
on a eu des soucis techniques à un
moment au tout début de saute il y avait
simplement des réunions en permanence
nuit des jours pour essayer de régler
les problèmes de calibrer etc cette
mission va se va durer quand même
plusieurs
alors j'ai plus le chiffre en tête deux
ou trois ans je crois donc on est encore
dans une phase de de de recettes et de
calibration de de la mission elle est
pas encore opérationnelle et fournit pas
encore les données ou les données aux
scientifiques les images enfin en tout
cas les premiers résultats qu'on a et
les images qu'on a sont sont au-delà de
ce qu'on espérait ils sont absolument
sont absolument incroyables mais c'est
un petit peu tôt pour faire un bilan
scientifique de ce qui a été de ce qui a
été obtenu
peut-être un dernier mot sur la Guyane
parce que ah oui les sur le la question
sur le CNES peut-être et puis après sur
la Guyane
donc bien entendu oui alors le rapport
de la Cour des comptes on a évidemment
étudié étudier attentivement
je
suis plutôt plutôt intéressé par les
propositions enfin les les
conclusions de la cour et les
recommandations que je trouve plutôt
constructive et plutôt très positif
évidemment
toujours des recommandations mais enfin
je trouve que c'est un rapport que je
que je trouve plutôt positif pour pour
le CNES en particulier il y a Hitler il
est mis en avant le fait que le CNES
maîtrise à la fois ses projets et ses
budgets ce qui ce qui contenus de la
nature de notre établissement est quand
même absolument essentiel vu les
montants de subventions pour charger les
services publics qu'on reçoit c'est
c'est juste absolument fondamental donc
effectivement un des un des points qui
étaient mentionnés par la Cour c'était
c'était la question de la question de de
DRH et la question de d'une
effectivement de une forme de de
vieillissement des effectifs du de la
maison
j'ai envie de dire que la réponse elle
est aussi contenue dans la question
c'est à dire qu'on a un enjeu de faire
une gestion prévisionnelle des
compétences et des effectifs au sein du
CNES ça a déjà été lancé avant même le
rapport de le rapport d'inspection une
des difficultés de cet exercice c'est
que le collège on a c'est beaucoup
d'argent c'est relativement peu de
personnes de personnes 2500 personnes en
gros
et ce qui veut dire qu'en fait la
plupart de nos compétences c'est des
compétences qui sont
uniques ou ces quelques personnes c'est
un nombre très très limité de personnes
qui sont compétentes sur des sujets qui
sont des sujets très techniques vraiment
très pointues et donc c'est ça qui fait
la force du CNES c'est la somme de ses
compétences et qui sont des compétences
uniques c'est pas c'est pas une équipe
de 30 personnes qui travaillent sur tel
type de propulseur c'est beaucoup plus
fin et beaucoup plus précis que ça donc
c'est toute la difficulté de cette
gestion des compétences et le fait
qu'évidemment quand on a une personne
qui parle il faut avoir prévu
préalablement la formation des
précédents et le et le retour donc oui
on a des on a plus de turn over chez les
jeunes que chez les plus anciens
c'est pas spécifique je crois au CNES
c'est quelque chose qu'on voit aussi
c'est sans doute un effet générationnel
on en trouve beaucoup parlé dans la dans
les journaux
c'est aussi je pense quelque chose qu'on
retrouve dans d'autres établissements
publics comme similaire à ceux du CNES
dans d'autres épis
oui évidemment il y a on n'est pas sur
les niveaux de salaire de des
entreprises qui sont dans le secteur
c'est vrai je pense que c'est vrai c'est
pas complètement nouveau non plus ça a
toujours été il y a toujours eu il y a
toujours eu un décalage je pense que les
gens qui viennent aussi au CNES ils ont
aussi
[Musique]
un souhait de contribuer à cette mission
de service public de travailler pour une
agence de regarder des problèmes sous
des angles extrêmement divers et
extrêmement variés donc c'est aussi des
c'est aussi des profils enfin dit
autrement les gens ne viennent pas au
CNES simplement comme dans une
entreprise normale donc voilà je pense
que c'est important par contre que cet
écart ne se ne s'accroisse pas et c'est
vrai qu'il est en train de s'accroître
en ce moment pourquoi parce qu'il y a
une il y a un emballement autour du
spatial qui est extrêmement fort en
France et en Europe il y a un besoin de
talent et donc les salaires sont en
train de sont en train d'augmenter de
manière très significative et donc oui
on a un enjeu autour de ça
voilà et c'est un enjeu qui est
contraint puisque comme vous le savez
ces questions là sont très encadrées
sont très encadrés on n'est pas
uniquement de la responsabilité de la
direction du CNES
voilà donc
un mot peut-être sur la Guyane
j'ai mentionné les enjeux
environnementaux etc il y a eu la
question de est-ce que la France va
perdre sa place au CSG etc
donc évidemment le CSG fait l'objet d'un
certain nombre d'accord et de
conventions internationales il y a aussi
une convention entre la France et et les
a sur sur ce qu'est le CSG commençons
gérer les investissements je crois que
le rôle du CNES aujourd'hui est très
clair sur le sur le sur la base
c'est une base c'est c'est il faut voir
cette base spatiale qui a un endroit
extraordinaire très gros c'est la taille
de Singapour la base spatiale c'est
quand même c'est quand même c'est quand
même un endroit très très très vaste
mais c'est un site industriel c'est un
site industriel faut vraiment le voir
comme ça où vous avez tout un ensemble
d'industries d'usine qui produisent des
boosters d'un côté qui font l'assemblage
du lanceur de l'autre qui mettent la
charge utile un troisième endroit et
puis il faut faire des gaz aussi qui
vont être utilisés par le lanceur donc
qui est un liquide enfin donc c'est
vraiment c'est un signe industriel avec
dit et puis il y a plusieurs lanceurs
dont différents c'est un site industriel
on a un rôle évidemment de coordination
de ce site industriel coordination des
fluides qui fait quoi qui va où etc et
c'est et je crois qu'il est clair
aujourd'hui je crois pas qu'il soit qui
soit qui soit structurellement qui soit
structurellement menacé par contre une
évolution qui qui est en cours en ce
moment aujourd'hui c'est que on a été
pendant très longtemps sur une base
spatiale qui était exclusivement lente
utilisée par des lanceurs de l'Agence
spatiale européenne
alors qu'on voit aujourd'hui des
lanceurs privés qui viennent aujourd'hui
et qui veulent venir lancer sur la base
spatiale des lanceurs privés pour la
très grande majorité européen qui
viennent enfin de pays qui sont des
membres de lézard donc mais qui
développent des lanceurs en dehors du
cadre de les a et qui nous disent est-ce
que vous pourriez les lancer et donc moi
je pense qu'évidemment oui il faut y
aller mais évidemment ça change un petit
peu la Perse la perspective et la
dynamique de la base je pense que ce
phénomène là va probablement
s'accentuer dans les années dans dans
les années qui viennent donc voilà je
pense que je suis pas du tout inquiet
sur le fait que il y ait une perte
d'autonomie ou de régulation voilà parce
que parce qu'il y a un cadre il y a des
accords internationaux il y a une loi il
y a donc je suis pas inquiet sur le fait
que le fait que la France puis je crois
qu'il y a une volonté très claire de la
France de voilà enfin on assume une très
grande partie des coûts sur la base
spatiale
ça fait partie de voilà d'accord il est
d'accord il est cet équilibre il est
autour de ça je pense que il sera pas
remis en cause dans les dans les années
qui viennent
peut-être un mot sur iris Square et
après je pense que j'aurais fait le tour
donc évidemment oui en fonction du
calendrier il peut y avoir un peu de
d'encombrement sur les lancements et
évidemment on tient absolument à ce que
les lancements institutionnels européens
soit les soins institutionnels européens
prioritaires pour pour nous c'est c'est
évident maintenant les satellites d'iris
square ils sont pas encore là ils sont
pas encore construits ils sont pas
encore designés non plus ça va le
calendrier est très très ambitieux
évidemment mais mais la question enfin
tout ça elle va se gérer de manière
dynamique et ça c'est le travail
d'Ariane espace je pense que ça va très
bien faire ça et évidemment il y a aussi
un équilibre il faut qu'on je crois
aussi très profondément pour la France
et pour l'Europe il faut car il soit un
lanceur qui ne soit pas seulement un
lanceur institutionnel il faut aussi que
ce soit un lanceur qui soit un succès
spatial un succès commercial pardon
spatial aussi mais un succès commercial
et je crois que c'est une vision qui est
totalement partagée par par aussi bien
par Martin Sion que par Stéphanie straël
chez Ariane espace
c'est très très clair et il y a un
certain nombre de succès contractuels
qu'il faut qu'on honore et je crois que
c'est très positif pour la France et
pour l'Europe donc il faut pas le
négliger cet aspect là
très bien merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président comme d'habitude
les auditions du CNES les vôtres sont
tout à fait passionnantes nous ouvrent
un peu de regarder un peu voilà au loin
et au loin voilà mais pas si loin que ça
bon je pense que dans peut-être voilà
donc ce qui n'a pas été abordé il y a
toujours des problèmes à l'intérieur de
l'ESAT de rapports de force peut-être
entre les pays européens mais ça fera
l'objet probablement d'autres
discussions en tout cas merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président de vous recevoir
merci à mes collègues d'avoir résisté je
leur demande de rester quelques instants
parce qu'il y a un autre point lors du
jour très rapide et à très bientôt très
bien merci encore de votre invitation et
si je me permets juste de
prolonger une invitation à l'ensemble
des parlementaires aussi bien pour
visiter les établissements du CNES ou
pour assister à un tir à un tir en
Guyane
préparez vos affaires préparez vous avez
fait